ça y est endgame est passé et bon sang
quel film
nous sommes clairement à la fin du mc eu
enfin la phase iii plutôt ce film est
réellement une sorte de conclusion à
tous le mc eu bien qu'il reste quand
même far from home pour clôturer tout
cette épopée
néanmoins comme vous savez il y aura des
suites à une game marvel est loin d'en
avoir encore fini pour notre plus grand
plaisir
je vous propose aujourd'hui d'essayer
d'analyser le potentiel à venir de
chaque héros d'un game assez brièvement
nous sommes bien évidemment sur une
vidéo 100% subjective et tout ce que je
dis n'engage que moi
évidemment cette vidéo va totalement
spoliés endgame donc si vous ne l'avez
pas vu je vous conseille directement de
faire marche arrière
vous êtes prévenus pour les personnes
restantes écouter n'hésitez pas à
laisser votre plus gros pouce bleus et
activer la cloche puisque nous sommes
partis entre man la guêpe anc et janet
antoine c'est clairement propulsé comme
un héros majeur avec l'histoire d'anne
game il est celui qui a ravivé la flamme
et trouver la solution permettant la
victoire face à la noce et je pense
sincèrement que ce kon va continuer à
nous surprendre
première chose à chaque film scott
devient de plus en plus experts du chant
quantique
il est clair que lui accompagné de la
guêpe et ses parents vont terminer la
mission qu'ils effectué avant l'arrivée
de thanos ghost sera donc soigné par les
quatre protagonistes qui vont continuer
leurs expériences sur le champ quantique
entre mana fait de sérieuses découverte
avec le voyage dans le temps et
l'exploration quantique n'est plus un
problème de fond sincèrement que la
troisième origin story sur antoine sera
centrée sur l'exploration quantique à
son paroxysme et je les vois bien faire
la découverte du multivers ce lieu
incontournable des comics qui
permettrait de lancer l'arrivée des
dimensions parallèles ou autre univers
il est même d'ailleurs possible que pour
notre ami antoine
à force de faire des allers et venues
dans le champ quantique ce dernier voit
ses capacités se développer en quelque
sorte
évidemment enquête jeannette vont
apporter un savoir et une connaissance
énorme pour le développement de tout ce
qui concerne le champ quantique mais
surtout ils ne seront plus seuls
puissent
la guerre stark pim se termine avec une
game et puis les avengers ont maintenant
connaissance de la dimension et surtout
du sérum de pim
bref il ya encore énormément de choses à
venir aux cayes
j'ai vraiment apprécié aux cayes dans in
game il était à la base l'un des
avengers que gmail - et je trouve qu'ici
il a clairement une très belle évolution
aux cayes souffre du même syndrome que
black widow il n'est qu'un terriens sans
pouvoir mais qui sait se battre
bien que tout de même puissant hawk eye
ne peut pas aller au front d'une
bataille et surtout vu l'évolution que
va prendre le mc eu avec la phase 4 aux
cayes va vite être dépassée déjà il n'a
plus aucune raison de redevenir ronin sa
famille est réapparu et il est sûr d'une
chose barton va se rendre disponible
pour cette dernière et en profiter un
maximum
il a même perdu la seule avengers qui
pouvait réellement le comprendre
sa coéquipière natacha il est assuré que
clint va prendre une sorte de retraite
et s'isoler pour s'occuper de sa famille
un repos bien mérité black widow la mort
de natasha un petit peu laissé sur ma
faim pour ne rien vous cacher l'héroïne
n'a même pas eu de funérailles alors que
pourtant elle est importante dans le
groupe des avengers c'est quelque chose
que je trouve vraiment étrange alors que
tony même s'il est plus important que
natacha a le droit à des obsèques dignes
de ce nom
pourquoi cette négligence je vous pose
cette question les obsèques permettent
de signer la fin d'un personnage à 100%
et préparer notre deuil pour passer à
autre chose mais pas avec natacha je
pense que vous savez ce que je vais dire
mais natacha et est donc lié à la pierre
de lâm dông games et comme camorra fut
enfermé dedans à la non connaissance de
nos héros enfin à part peut-être aux
cayes à 47 par réellement ce qu'il s'est
passé après qu'il ait récupéré la pierre
danos avait pu retrouver gamme aura un
court instant après le claquement de
doigts il se peut que banner via son
snap ait pu retrouver natasha également
il affirme même qu'il a essayé de la
ramener en même temps que les autres
pareil pour tony avant de mourir ce
dernier a également effectué un snap
néanmoins
comparé à banner il ne possède pas de
lien particulier avec l'héroïne
bref on ne sait pas trop ce qu'implique
la pierre de larmes dans le mc eu mais
il se pourrait que sans le savoir steve
en ramenant les pierres car les avengers
n'ont plus besoin est ramenée natacha
sur vos remirent une âme contre une
autre il est possible que les changes
s'effectue de façon inversée malgré les
réticences de hockey à ce sujet dans le
film nous pourrions alors retrouver
natasha qui auraient survécu sur vomir
et resterait seul avec red skull
mais alors comment survivre et elle ou
bien est-ce qu'elle prendrait la place
de crâne rouge du coup c'est un très
gros mystère à élucider
dans tous les cas ne vous crée pas de
faux espoirs quant à son retour wendat
wang a été la seule à bonnes moeurs à
pouvoir ralentir la noce dans infinity
ward et qu'est ce que ça fait du bien de
la voir se déchaîner et révéler toute sa
puissance
la sorcière rouge a encore beaucoup de
choses à montrer et va prendre du galon
nous la voyons à la fin d une game en
compagnie de hawkeye tout en se
rappelant de son frère vif argent et de
vision elle doit tourner la page wendat
est comme une sorte de petit fort
lointaine pour hawkeye et je pense que
nous les reverrons ensemble très
prochainement
okah et symbolisme au rwanda une sorte
de figure paternelle qui lui a toujours
manqué et surtout elle est désormais
seule suite à la mort de vision et son
frère encore avant wendat pourrait
combler également un manque chez barton
qui vient tout juste de perdre natacha
qui était pour lui comme une soeur
adoptive wendat lui permettrait de
retrouver cette figure féminine qui lui
apportait beaucoup également n'oublions
pas souri dans l'infiniti wars souris
avaient pour mission de délier lapierre
et visions mission qui se termine a
prématurément à cause de l'ordre noir
néanmoins schori et d'une intelligence
et est une savante hors pair je pense
sincèrement qu'elle a réussi à tirer
quelque chose du peu de temps qu'elle
possédait
ce n'est d'ailleurs pas détaillé dans
endgame vu le peu de temps où elle
apparaît à l'écran vision pourrait être
une sorte d'intelligence artificielle
comme le fut jarvis
je crois réellement c'est une
possibilité mais cela reste un avis
personnel je vous le rappelle steve
rodgers steve fait énormément débat les
voyages temporels sont compliqués à
maîtriser à comprendre et je vous avoue
que moi même par moments je me perds au
moment de ramener les pierres dans leur
véritable époque ainsi que le mjolnir
steve fait le choix de retourner à son
époque pour retrouver pegi est passé des
jours heureux
je suis tellement content pour captain
ça faisait un moment que j'y pensais et
je suis ravi que ça soit arrivé
le cas de steve est en effet particulier
ce dernier a donc décidé de ne pas
revenir et faire sa vie avec peggy
jusqu'à se marier avec elle je ne vais
pas spécialement détailler les
conséquences car pour moi il y en a je
ne vais rien vous cacher nous verrons ça
dans une prochaine vidéo car il ya
beaucoup mais beaucoup de choses à dire
il avait d'ailleurs fait une vidéo
théorie sur avengers endgame qui n'a
jamais été aussi actuel par rapport à
captain je vous invite à aller la voir
steve à l'heure actuelle va prendre sa
retraite et se retirer des avengers au
point de déléguer le rôle de captain
america au faucon et c'est
compréhensible dans l'avenir je pense
que captain sera consultable comme un
personnage de sagesse jusqu'au jour de
sa mort avec les plus grands honneurs
qu'il mérite
la panthère et souris sourit on y est
déjà revenu par le biais de wendat et la
reconstruction de vision mais il est
clair que son personnage va continuer à
se développer et elle épaulera toujours
xala qui d'ailleurs en aura besoin suite
à la fin du premier film black panthères
xala souhaite s'ouvrir au monde et
arrêter de cacher le wakanda sans
compter les péripéties dignes finity war
et endgame où ce dernier a renforcé ses
liens avec les avengers depuis civil war
notamment la panthère a énormément à
nous montrer surtout avec son origin
story qui ne fait que de commencer le
héros va rentrer sérieusement dans la
politique internationale et devra
défendre le wakanda coûte que coûte
c'est une autre facette de marvel que
nous allons découvrir avec de sérieuses
enjeux politiques et des ennemis
puissants
mais pas en terme de pouvoir brutes mais
en terme de pouvoir politique
du moins je l'espère nous ne sommes
qu'au début de la vie de black panthères
spider man far from home le second opus
de l'origine story de spider man sera le
film qui clôturera la phase trop et je
pense vous faire une vidéo sur les
enjeux justement de ce film qui du coup
bas clôture la phase 3 si ce film est
défini comme le dernier de la phase iii
ce qu'il va apporter les réponses et
accessoirement nous montrer le prologue
de la guerre d'infini face à la noce
dans ce film spider man souhaitera
arrêté d'enfiler la tenue de héros pour
quelque temps et redevenir un adolescent
normal ce pendant huit heures ne peut
esquiver ses responsabilités et sa
destinée aux jeunes héros était le petit
protégé de tony stark lui même un des
piliers fondateurs des avengers et aussi
pour nick fury site owni faisait
confiance au jeune garçon fiori va
forcément s'intéresser à lui biedermann
va grandir va mûrir et nous ne sommes
qu'à l'aube de son succès en tant
qu'arrangeur et en termes de puissance
nick fury va former le jeune justicier
et chaque épreuve de la vie que subit
peter le fait avancer et grandir
mystérieux le prochain méchant qu'il
devra affronter va lui donner du fil à
retordre un personnage très intelligent
maître des illusions et également
manipulateur le jeune héros qui possède
toujours un brin de naïveté due à sa
jeunesse devra prendre conscience de
certaines choses et mûrir
bref nous reparlerons de far from home
sous un autre aspect mais je pense
sincèrement que spider man sera le héros
qui va de montrer la plus grande courbe
de croissance en termes d'évolution dans
le mc eu
endgame est clairement pour moi le film
de l'année je ne pense pas qu'un autre
film réussir est elle dépassée au fond
de moi cette vidéo qui à la base devait
être une seule et même partie du coût
sera coupé en deux parties pour que ce
soit plus digeste il ya tellement de
héros je ne pensais pas que ça serait si
long je m'en rends compte pendant le
tournage la deuxième partie est censé
arriver dès demain donc n'hésite pas à
ta bonne et pour ne pas la louper
j'ai d'ailleurs un concours d'actifs sur
twitter où je vous fait gagner une
figurine pop
thanos et nebula de endgame donc bref
foncé c'était argot rock et que le liner
soit avec vous
[Musique]